what becomes dangerous is if
you know the person who i agree with
politically
also has the same ethnicity as me also
goes to the same church as me also as
part of the same little league team as
me and the outside of a person who i
distrust
is just a stranger in all realms of life
because then it becomes easy to actually
vilify them to such an extent
that that that you're capable of doing
terrible things to them
[Music]
hello and welcome to trigonometry i'm
francis foster i'm constantine kitchen
and this is a show for you if you want
honest conversations with fascinating
people our brilliant guest today is a
political scientist whose latest book is
called the great experiment why diverse
democracies fall apart and how they can
endure yasha monk welcome to
trigonometry
thanks so much for having me on
it's a real pleasure to have you on
we've been you and i have been messaging
back and forth for for years now uh
trying to get you on the show i'm
pleased that we we can do this now with
your book uh coming out which francis
and i both really enjoyed uh before we
talk about it and and the case you make
in the book uh tell everybody a little
bit about who are you how are you where
you are what has been your journey
through life that leads you to be
sitting here talking to us
great yeah i think we have probably we
haven't talked about this as somewhat
similar background my grandparents
originally are from uh were born in lev
in colombia in what's now the western
part of ukraine
um
they uh
ended up the jewish they ended up
surviving the holocaust in the soviet
union actually went to poland uh in
hopes of you know building up
a better political regime we were
uncommunists they realized that
the hopes were misplaced and were in
fact thrown out of the communist regime
uh in 1968 and so i ended up growing up
a little strangely in in germany
um and then went to went to university
in england um spent spend a few very
nice years there before coming to united
states for grad school
and so now i've been living in america
for you know about 12 15 years and my
intellectual journey is that i thought i
would do various things without the
theater and a bunch of different things
but in the end i sort of got stuck on on
writing and academia
um and when i was a grad student in
political science
i was
um surprised to hear
the consensus in the field being
that certain countries in the world just
have these very stable democratic
institutions these very stable
democratic systems so we don't have to
worry at all
about how democracy will play out in
countries like britain like the united
states like germany
and perhaps in part and formed by the
history of my family i thought hey i've
seen a couple of big historical
surprises
um and i'm not so sure that's true and
so i started to to to warn about some of
the threats to our democracy
um
and and that's sort of how i made my
name and so um my last book was called
the people versus democracy and it was
about the threat of authoritarianism and
populists on the right and also on the
left
uh and and this book is really trying to
think about you know i think one of the
things that is making this political
moment so fraud which is um how do we
build these deeply ethnically and
religiously diverse democracies
that treat the members fairly without
falling apart without fragmenting
without making everything about group
identity without
oppressing some people in terrible ways
um so that's what i meant
well it's a really interesting book and
i want to delve into it but before that
can we talk a little bit about history
because it seems to me and i i i'm
welcome being corrected on this the the
experiment that we are conducting in the
west
is an experiment and it is unique in
terms of human history historically
speaking my understanding is generally
even multi-ethnic empires whether that
was the ottomans or the russian empire
there was they all the you know various
chinese empires they tended to be a
primary ethnic group that was considered
superior and all the others would would
be some form of second-class citizens
that they wouldn't necessarily be
persecuted but they would have reduced
rights or they would have to pay special
kind of tax or something how unique is
the sort of
multi-ethnic
multicultural societies that we are now
experimenting with in the west
yeah so this is one of the things that i
uh you know had a sense of before
writing the book but research much more
deeply
as i was preparing to write it and um
you know historical precedents are not
good
um you see that a lot of the worst
conflicts in human history
pit these different ethnic
religious
cultural sometimes national groups
against each other not every big crime
in history is along those lines but most
of the big crimes in history most of the
wars and civil wars and genocides and
forms of ethnic cleansing
do
pit one group against another in that
kind of way
and the history of democracy is not
great either because actually most
democracies in the history of the world
have either prided themselves in the
ethnic purity or at least in the ethnic
purity of those who really had something
to say
that's true in ancient athens and the
roman republic and
the city states of medieval italy
or like the united states they were
founded at the moment when we were
diverse but they excluded and and
oppressed some groups in in in terrible
ways as as was the case obviously
uh with slavery and so
um
actually the kind of multi-ethnic
empires you're talking about
um are some of the better examples um
are some of the places where people were
relatively free to go about the religion
were places where for a few centuries at
least these different groups managed to
coexist somewhat peacefully
but but as you're saying obviously there
was still one dominant group and it did
have privileges it did have a lot uh
more standing there was real
restrictions on minority groups um and
obviously we want to live in a democracy
and uh you know paradoxically the
empires made it a little bit easier and
in one key respect which is that in an
empire you don't have power and i don't
have power
and so if your group has more kids or
there's more immigrants that look like
you rather than me doesn't really change
anything because you know we didn't have
power to start off with we sort of had
to rely on the monarch um in a democracy
you're always looking for a majority and
so if you feel like hey i'm in the
majority group and now suddenly there's
these other people coming in and they're
having more kids and they're growing
more quickly than i am ben perhaps i
will lose power so in certain ways uh
you know it's not a coincidence that
despite their flaws some of the
countries where the coexistence of these
different groups has worked the best
precisely where these big
multi-ethnic empires
because in certain respects
um
absolute rule makes it easier than
democracy to sustain that kind of
difference
it's a very very good point and looking
at an empire which has got
many diverse people many diverse
cultures into one melting pot as it were
perfect example is the united states of
america
but i would say to you yeshua and maybe
this is me looking at it from an outside
eye the u.s seems more divided than ever
well it certainly does um and sometimes
looking at it you know i sort of have
two hats right i've been living united
states long enough but i feel uh like
i'm really in this political discourse
i'm i've become a united states citizen
i've been a citizen now for about five
years um
but looking at it sometimes from europe
you do think wow i mean for all of the
problems we have in various european
countries just the sheer rank of the
division the thing that really strikes
me the disdain that people have for each
other in this country but it stayed
statement many of my friends have for
average americans just goes so much
deeper and it's so much more extreme
than
than what i know from europe so i think
that's right
um but my book is actually quite
optimistic so here's something that i've
noticed about the way that people talk
about this topic which is that
uh look the fundamental starting point
is really tough right a lot of the
biggest crimes in history are pit one
group against another as i said
democracy makes it harder in some ways
there's a third point which is that um
humans
um
tend to form groups and favor the
members of the in-group over everybody
else um
and we tend to think about that as other
people doing it but we all have this
instinct so i'm really struck by the
fact that i teach a bunch of kids
uh you know i'm a college professor and
um
i have a very diverse student body and
they they think of themselves as some of
the most tolerant people in the world um
in some ways they are quite tolerant and
otherwise were quite intolerant but um
you know
they don't think that they're groupish
right they don't think that they would
ever treat somebody better because
they're a member of the same group over
somebody else and i haven't played this
simple game where i ask them is a hot
dog a sandwich
and they debate that for a little while
and they think what on earth does that
have to do with political science but
they also clearly enjoy it i mean i
haven't played a little group where they
have to uh give people points um but
they can you know redeem for a little
bit of money
and it turns out with the kids who think
that hot dog as a sandwich start to
discriminate against the kids who think
that a hot dog is not a sandwich so a
question like that is actually enough to
motivate this in-group favoritism
mechanism right and so
you take those three points of
difficulties together and you realize
that uh it's really hard to build
diverse democracies and it's not a
surprise that we sometimes are divided
it's not a surprise that we have real
injustices but that actually allows you
to be a little bit optimistic because
then you say hey the task what we're
trying to accomplish here is really hard
but you know what when you look even at
a divided country like the united states
we're doing a lot better at it than a
lot of other countries around the world
we're doing a lot better at it than so
many societies that have failed in
history we're doing a lot better than
america did 150 years ago
um
and a lot of people come to this topic
and the other way around right they're
like this should be easy how hard is it
to tolerate your neighbor how hard is it
not to be a bigot and then they look at
the injustices in our society but are
real and they say oh my god there's
something uniquely wrong with us how can
we have any hope for the future so i
think when you start with a realistic
appreciation of the difficulty of what
we're doing you can actually come to an
optimistic point of view whereas what a
lot of people do is they start with
really naive assumption but this
shouldn't be hard um and then they end
up being really fatalistic because of
the problems but we do see in in the
real world
yasha and again correct me if i'm wrong
my attitude has always been and i think
this is something my parents have
inculcated in me when they sent me as a
someone from russia over to the uk
was the idea of what you might call the
civic patriotism which is
the the solution to our inherent
evolutionary developed tribalism is to
build this thing called the nation state
to which you can subscribe no matter
what your skin color what your
religion is whatever as long as you buy
into the idea that we're all american or
we're all british or we're all whatever
um
is that the answer here because in your
book you look at that as one of the
potential solutions and that is not
without its challenges either
yes i think it's an important part of
the answer right so let me take a
another step back perhaps to start off
with i mean when i was growing up
my parents it's interesting that your
parents you know uh
uh sort of taught you like civic
patriotism is part of your answer i
think my
mom in particular taught me something
slightly different when i was growing up
which is to be skeptical of any form of
group right so she thought about
her history of being thrown out of a
country she grew up in when she was 20
and
her parents history of um you know
having to flee for war and losing most
of her family in the holocaust and she
blamed quite reasonably in a way this
groupish mechanism of humans right this
we are the in-group and you're the out
group and um
we're gonna be really altruistic towards
member of the in groups actually
sometimes capable of huge
courage and and altruism um but uh you
know if you're not part of the group we
can do whatever we want to you and so
she i think hoped
that we would all identify as
individuals or perhaps as cosmopolitans
right that we would all think of
ourselves in our own individual terms
and care about everybody in the world
equally
and that was uh very appealing to me um
uh as a moral vision i think there's
something of it but we should preserve
but it's just not a realistic
uh prescription for how most people in
the world are going to act and it's not
realistic for me for myself either right
if i hear of an earthquake or a terror
attack
somewhere in the world but i've never
been but i don't know very well i'm
saddened by it and i want to help and
and and i want to think about how to
avoid that but if i see
a tower attack in in london which is a
city i know well where where i've lived
for a while or in new york city on the
subway but but i take myself i'm
affected in a different way and that's
just part of human nature right we might
want to push against a little bit say
hey we should also care about people far
away and let's not make it too easy for
ourselves but we're always going to care
a little bit more when it's places we
know um where we can picture you know
countries where we have a real deep
connection to
and the same is true about you know
religious and other groups right people
will always have strong religious
beliefs they will always identify in
part by the kind of cultural origins
they have and to some extent perhaps but
always define by their ethnicity too and
i don't think we can ever quite get rid
of that right so we need to think about
how do we build a society in which
people have
individual freedoms in which they can
determine themselves how they want to
lead their lives in which they can be
true to the kind of groups in which
they're in and which they have religious
freedom obviously in which they can say
hey i just want to be with people who
have a similar kind of cultural
background with me and mostly hang out
with those people and so on and that's
perfectly fine too
but that comes naturally
what is harder and what we really need
to sustain our countries to stop them
from falling apart to to stop
the risk of civil war to stop
deeply fragmented societies is where we
always
have a level of identity where we have
something in common and that to me is
the importance of having uh an inclusive
national
identity having the kind of civic
patriotism that you're talking about or
actually in my account also a kind of
everyday cultural patriotism
and yeshua you've you've touched on this
about you know the the need and the the
deep-seated need for people to form
tribes but there's also a physiological
aspect to that in that the hormone
oxytocin that quite literally binds us
together also gives us a suspicion of
the outside because that's how we
survived on the on the african savannas
so that's another layer of challenge
isn't it trying to get people to
override and get over that particular
instinct
yeah jonathan hyde in the righteous mind
is is really great on this and showing
uh how
satisfying it can be to be a member of
of of of of groups how it can bring out
the best in us
um
and that is to do probably with this
hormone that gets triggered when we're
doing when we're done you know when
we're dancing together or we're singing
a song together you're at the you know
you're at the football stadium and
you're singing the song of your home
team together with thousands of people
there's something with that experience
triggers in us which is kind of high
um
and and it can make us feel loving
towards other people it can it can
uh make us uh
risk our lives um it is in in part
what's happening in ukraine today where
millions of people
are
volunteering uh to risk their lives uh
to stop this this terrible invasion from
from vladimir putin's troops so so so
these forms of collective
um
being together
sometimes in the form of
at the national level of patriotism
sometimes in the form of your football
team or whatever you know your friends
being out singing karaoke together it
can be different forms of group
is really positive but as you're saying
it then also pushes very quickly to say
well hang on a second but if a member of
our group is threatened we're gonna go
and beat you up right if there's
something that that threatens this group
from the outside true or imagined
i'm also gonna be capable of this sort
of deep bureaucracy against others now
one of the solutions to this is but you
don't want a society in which groups are
really monolithic right so uh one of the
things i research from my book is sort
of modes of failure right how do diverse
societies go wrong there's all kinds of
ways they go wrong they can be
uh so many different groups and they
never agree on building a state in the
first place so you never get public
services you never get
uh
an effective state um like in
afghanistan and parts of somalia right
you have these extreme forms of
domination where one group dominates and
just oppresses the others like we've had
in in large parts of the history of the
united states um
but you can also have
what's happening in lebanon so it's such
a deep fragmentation that you know
there's barely any lebanese identity
what there is is sunni and shia and
maryland christian identity
and those groups are really monolithic
and the system wants them to be
monolithic um because it works and
there's a compromise between elites but
the elites can only represent the groups
if the groups are really stable and
don't interact with each other very much
right and then it becomes dangerous
because the moment that's triggered it's
like you know i'm a shia a hundred
percent and i have nothing that connects
me with somebody who's a suny have
nothing but connection with somebody
who's a miranda christian and that then
raises the very little risk of
of civil war in a healthy society you
might say hey i'm in church and and that
gives me serotonin it gives me a sense
of being along my fellow worshipers um
but you know some of the people who
don't go to my church
um are in my son's little league game
and
you know we're supporting the same team
there and so i have a sort of sense of
connection with him in that context
right um and then you know some of the
people who are neither of that perhaps
are part of the same political party
that i support and so even as we're
divided in some spheres of life we also
have connections in other spheres of
life that's something that sort of helps
to to to control that instinct to say
it's the outgroup what becomes dangerous
is if
you know the person who i agree with
politically
also has the same ethnicity as me also
goes to the same church as me also as
part of the same little league team as
me and the outside of a person who i
distrust is just a stranger in all
realms of life because then it becomes
easy to actually vilify them to such an
extent
that that very capable of doing terrible
things to them
hey constantine do you love trigonometry
i'm from russia i cannot love anything
apart from vodka miserable literature
and a horrendous downfall of my people
but yes i find trigonometry satisfactory
and do you like live shows
of course but only if it's check of play
about collapse of russian aristocracy as
they face death and obscurity before the
glorious might of the proletariat and
the beautiful revolution
okay mate well if you like trigonometry
live shows then get your credit card out
for the lads because we're coming to the
edinburgh festival this august we have
only booked two shows august 6th and 7th
because if we do more the comedy
industry will treat us like the tsars
and execute us that's right we're going
to be in edinburgh for two days only
saturday's guest is andrew doyle which
is sure to sell out our other guest is
leo curse which means when nicola
sturgeon hears about it she'll ban us
from scotland herself tickets are sure
to sell out and when they're gone
they're gone click on the link below and
we'll see you in edinburgh on the 6th
and 7th of august at the gilded balloon
teviet
come and see us before hordes of
left-wing comedians try to put us in
gulag
what do we do then with identity
politics which encourages people to see
themselves in this way which encourages
people to tribalize which encourages
people to think that they're oppressed
that the society that they live in is
biased against them that they're never
going to have the same opportunities as
x group what do we do with that
yeah so look i
one of the weird things about this topic
is that no damn term you can use
actually describes well and neutrally
what we're talking about right and and
these terms that seem equivalent have
slightly different uh connotations so
identity politics or woke or whatever
they all mean slightly different things
and we're all kind of embattled weird
concepts so um so let's be precise about
what we're talking about um because i
believe in in this group of us that
people have because i think that people
are always going to form those groups
and sort of fight for interest there's
certain forms of identity politics that
i'm fine with right the fact that there
is
um to name a silly example of the
american association of retired people
right that fights the interest of
elderly people um wants to make sure
that we preserve social security and we
have a bunch of other kinds of that's
perfectly fine right and there's other
forms of interest group politics that'll
always exist in a free society
but i'm not too not too concerned about
not too worried about so if all we mean
by identity politics is
people have those group identities and
they're going to have associations
uh
that fight yeah
sorry it's interesting sorry to
interrupt let's just make this simple
though we're not talking about people
who are retired because we're all going
to be retired one day if we live that
long what we're talking about identity
when we mean we see use the term
identity politics is exclusionary ways
of looking at different groups
particularly through the lens of race
sex sexuality uh whether you're
trans or not etc this kind of thing
where these are not things that will
ever bring people together
like francis and i we have different
ethnic backgrounds but we'll we will
both eventually get to a point where
we're retired do you know what i mean
hopefully uh where's what right yeah i i
i i know what he's saying i i was
working up to it so i'm an academic you
know i i do a lot of i do a lot of
public stuff but sometimes my my
professorial thing comes through you
know sometimes i have to take a long run
up to something you'll have to go for it
so look the same is true for
the american armenian association right
that's pushing for congress to
recognize the armenian genocide right
or for the american of the world jewish
congress which looks out for the
interest of jews in various kinds of
ways and for the naacp uh which looks
out for the interest of blacker marx
that's fine i'm not worried about that
because that certain you know not
everybody's going to be jewish not
everybody's going to be armenian so
that's different from the uh sort of
association photography but that's okay
right it's perfectly fine for people to
say hey jews have particular kinds of
interests and particular kinds of
concerns and worries and we need an
organization that is capable of
representing that politically so if all
you were talking about about that
politics was that i wouldn't be so
concerned now as you're saying identity
politics today is a lot more than that
and and there i start to get concerned
very quickly so let me give you one
concrete example
um
one of the things i i talk about in the
book is is is a deep research program in
in in psychology for 75 years it's one
of the most well established findings
which is intergroup contact theory right
and it shows that
uh when we
spend time with people from different
groups against whom we have might have
prejudices and the right kind of context
when we reduce versus prejudices so in
one famous study in 1950
um white bostonians who had black
neighbors ended up having more positive
views of them than white westonians who
were randomly assigned to similar
housing units that were segregated right
but there's important conditions around
that you need to be in a situation in
which
you're equal within the situation even
if you might not be equal in other parts
of society you have a common set of
goals and you're being encouraged to to
get along by by authorities right
now let's talk about what a lot of
indeed private schools have started to
do in the united states peop places like
horace mann and
uh
dalton in new york city place like
several friends in dc where presidents
tend to send their kids really
influential schools that show you a lot
about what's going on the american
league today right
there you have stu teachers coming in
when the kids are 10 or 8 or 6
and saying you african-american you're
going to that group over there you're
asian american you're going to that
group over there you're latino you're
going to go to that group over and
you're white we don't really know what
to do with you but i guess you're going
to go in that group over there
and
and the goal which is understandable is
um
to make people aware of some of the
discrimination they might suffer and to
make them more capable to fight for the
interest and so on but when you're
taking kids that young and you're
telling them from from on high the most
important thing about you is the color
of your skin or or your origin
um that just hardens
these groups in extreme ways and by the
way the hope is to take these white kids
and turn them into d'angelo style
anti-racist if you know anything about
serotonin if you know anything about um
the way that groups tend to work you're
much more likely to create racists
you're much more likely to create people
who say well my identity is being white
i'm gonna fight for the interests of
white people like these other groups are
fighting for their interests right and
so um when identity politics becomes
the celebration of and the encouragement
of group identities to the exclusion of
everything else
um
it can start to go really really wrong
and what would be a better kind of
pedagogical mechanism put them in a
sports team
right where they might start to hate the
sports team or the other high school
that's okay that's not going to tear our
society apart but within the sports team
we're going to feel inequality we're
going to feel a kinship we're going
be working together for a common goal
and then they might also have valuable
conversations where we're like hey
you know what i don't feel as seen with
school as i might or i you know i i come
from
uh you know a difficult situation at
home and and i i faced these
disadvantages and so on they're going to
be much more sympathetic to each other
much more open to each other because
their teammates are working on a common
goal and and and they start to like each
other they start to spend time with each
other so that's one of the many examples
in american society at the moment and
british and so on society too where the
wrong form of identity politics becomes
really dangerous yeah i agree and yes i
want to come promise you i'd get that it
took me a while
you did and maybe i shouldn't have
interrupted you i thought we could we
could cut some corners and get straight
into it but uh i'll i'll make sure that
you probably could have
yeah there we go so i want to come back
to something
you use in the book and something you
mentioned earlier where i kind of want
to
perhaps disagree with you or at least to
push and see see what comes back which
is you talk about this metaphor
of the melting pot and then some people
talk about the salad bowl right and the
melting pot basically means everybody
comes to america becomes american and no
one cares what the ethnicity is the
salad bowl is sort of like all the
people are in the salad but they're kind
of like the tomatoes are separate from
from the cucumbers right and you talk
about which ones puzzled me because that
sounds like a terrible salad
yeah good salad actually everybody is
mixed up so you know perhaps i like the
metaphor of a salad bowl if it's like
you know a sweet green salad anyway
right
and then of course you talk about the
way that it ought to be i think is is a
park where everybody can come and
everybody can sit next to each other and
have a picnic and mix as they wish or
not right and this is where i might
disagree with you because i know that
having lived in the uk you've seen that
we have had problems with integrating
certain communities into the family of
of british people if you like that there
are some people who've integrated very
well after coming to the uk and others
that are struggling they're not doing
very well they're not uh doing well in
education they're not doing well in
terms of uh embracing certain aspects of
british traditions and values they
they're not serving in the british
military and anything like the numbers
over every other group for example they
are excluded they live in separate areas
and so on is that not a problem that has
to be overcome for for our diverse
societies to triumph and succeed in the
future
um
look yeah so so let me talk through his
metaphors for a sec right you put very
well but the problem with the melting
pot is that it asks people to give up at
least in one reading of it i mean it's a
slightly unfair reading of a metaphor
but that is how people often talk about
it it asks people to give up too much of
a particularity right so it imagines
that
once everybody comes to britain or once
everybody comes to the states
the culture will best some of the
marks of their influence right like
the curry becomes the the typical
british dish in a certain kind of way
and
you know americans love spaghetti with
meatballs and you know kung pao chicken
or whatever but everybody within the
society is kind of indistinguishable
right um and i think that that with asks
people too much i think it's perfectly
fine for people to say i want to be 100
british but i also i'm going to continue
to be 100 indian or a hundred percent
chinese or whatever right i'm also going
to continue to want to be true to the
cultural heritage of my ancestors
there's no problem with that and in fact
it's one of the great things about these
countries today one of the reasons why i
love london why i love new york is that
you continue to see the influence of
those different cultures and that one
neighborhood of london feels a little
different from the other neighborhood
but everything isn't the same and about
every person not the same so so
so that's where that's from now the
salad bowl is really dangerous right
because it creates the kind of
separateness that i think you're worried
about right it pushes us to the point
where we say
we just live in these completely
different communities
and uh you know perhaps we somehow
managed to sustain the peace perhaps
um you know we're able to pay tax and
sustain a welfare state together but
really we have no points of connective
tissue we have no points of overlap at
all and and i do think that at a time
when
that form of multiculturalism was very
politically
fashionable
there were some real mistakes in terms
of policies people adopted so in britain
for example
the new labor government introduced
state-based faith schools
now
it's one thing in a free society for for
parents to say we want to send our kids
to a private school and that's a
faith-based school that that's the right
to do that but for the state to come in
and encourage people and say hey
uh you're hindu go to the hindu school
you're jewish go to the jewish school
you're muslim go to the muslim school
that i think is uh
really raising the risk
of having these completely separate
communities that don't speak to each
other mistrust each other and then also
become much more likely to harm each
other so so the salad bowl for that
reason i think is a is a real mistake
um and so my image is that of a public
park because of two things in a free
society you have a right to decide who
you hang out with right and if we have a
fun conversation as we're having we can
go to a park together after this
conversation and say we just want to be
among ourselves and keep this
conversation going we don't want to talk
to anybody else or we might say hey this
is a fun conversation and now we're kind
of feeling loose and perhaps there's
some fun people sitting next to us and
we get into a conversation with them and
we make more friends
in a free society you have a right to
either of those things you can be amish
and stay among the amish community all
of your life and that's your right to do
if all of society becomes like that
right or if there are some groups that
completely cut themselves off from the
rest of society in a way that
undermines any ability to sustain common
values
that becomes an economic problem that
becomes a problem of of potentially deep
mutual mistrust then then i really start
to worry so it's fine for some people to
say hey the most important thing about
me is my group and i'm going to remain a
member of it but looking at it from
above as it were looking at from the
outside you need enough people to have
enough of those connections but you
don't end up in the salad bowl but you
don't end up having these really
separate communities now
i don't know enough about the situation
describing to know whether or not that's
a fair description of some communities
in britain but certainly
if the description is as you say it is i
would agree that's a problem i would put
that under the salad bowl rather than
the public park
right
but i suppose what i'm saying is
um
if we accept as i completely accept your
idea that human beings are always prone
to tribalism
then unless people are encouraged by the
state
to
shed some of their past identity
right some not all but some
what possible reason would we have to go
to a park and communicate instead of
going to a park and going this is my
part of the park and you're not coming
in because this is where you know the
the the pointy hat people say and this
is where the flat hat people sit and
we're going to keep apart because that
is our instinct as you say what is going
to encourage us to do that if it's not
the state saying look we're all british
and you can cook the food you want and
and whatever but we all speak a certain
language we all buy into certain values
we all develop a sense of patriotism
about our country etc how is that going
to happen unless the
the the society encourages people to buy
into a single identity
um
well i think so so you said state once
you said society once and i'm much more
comfortable for society to do this than
for the state to do that it depends a
little bit on the context um
uh and it depends a little bit on the
kind of criminality you're talking about
but yes absolutely we should in
countries that's historically been the
case switzerland or whatever is a
different case but in britain in the
united states we should all end up
speaking the same
uh language and we should have
uh real uh
shared values with each other we should
agree on the fundamentals of how our
political society is governed and the
kind of mutual tolerance
that that entails and we absolutely need
social institutions including especially
schools and and universities
as well as media
that that encourage that um now i'm
actually quite optimistic about that so
language is a great case right you have
fears on the right that immigrants who
are coming in aren't really learning the
language of
whether it's english in britain with
states or german and germany and so on
um and you have some people on the left
saying they shouldn't
uh so there's a fashion book in the
states of environment which basically
says don't integrate at all if you know
if you're always gonna
speak spanish and always going to speak
chinese that's perfectly fine i think
that just messes with sociological
reality
um because sociologists have have a
really fascinating model
um
about how language acquisition works for
immigrants and it's striking how true it
is in in many many different contexts so
here's what happens right the first
generation comes in and especially if
they come from somewhat less educated
backgrounds they have less educational
opportunity especially if they come as
adults they often don't learn the
language very well some do but but many
people might live in a country for
decades and never fully learn the
language right
their children are going to speak both
languages well because they go to school
in english or german or whatever
language maybe um
but at home they they at least need to
understand the language of origin often
what happens at home actually is that
the parents speak to the language of
origin and they often respond in english
right
but the majority of these kids prefers
to speak english with their siblings
with their cousins with other people
from a similar background of migration
so they speak the language of origin
pretty well
but we prefer english by the third
generation by the generation of
grandparents of the immigrants
english or german or the language of a
new society wins a complete victory so
only about one percent of the
grandchildren of immigrants still speak
any of the language of origin now that
by the way is a little bit sad be nice
they spoke a little bit right um
uh but that just shows that um actually
the power of integration in our
societies remains very strong now
there's reason to worry about that in
the future as reasons to think about
under what circumstances would that
change but but for now i'm just actually
quite confident about the ability of
britain to turn the children the
grandchildren of people who come to the
country into people who feel british and
who are seen as british and and
certainly who speak english
hey constantine do you like trigonometry
of course what's not to love incredible
interviews hilarious raw shows plus
we're going to start doing weekly
satirical comedy like the ones that we
used to put out i'm constantly kissing
and you may remember me from my stint
hosting a kids tv show on al jazeera and
i'm francis foster a man who looks like
a cross between louis theroux and a
beaver
we are gonna start doing them but we
need your help as the show grows francis
and i are finding it increasingly
difficult to stay on top of everything
we've got to do with two interviews and
three raw shows every single week plus
loads of admin on top of that we've got
more work on than justin trudeau's
makeup artist do you miss comedy that's
actually funny comedy that pulls no
punches and isn't all about how we must
fight the structures of patriarchal
oppression by toxic straight white men
if you want real comedy you can make
that happen if we can get an extra 250
local supporters by march 15th we'll be
able to outsource a few of the
day-to-day things that we do and free up
more time to make incredible content for
you it will be funny biting satirical
and not some worthy [ __ ] telling you
what to think
[Laughter]
it's seven dollars a month which is five
pounds if you live in the civilized
world join our locals community using
the link in the description and help us
make comedy great again
yeah sure at the very start of the
interview you gave the example of the
sandwich
and whether people see a hot dog as a
sandwich and if they don't
and you found that people you know
were disagreeing and there was
discrimination going on but there's one
important thing that you mentioned yeah
sure
social media
people going
on social media on twitch and going
you're a [ __ ] idiot because you think
hot dog isn't do you know what i mean
there's a whole other element to this
conversation now which didn't exist 20
years ago
um yeah absolutely and one of the things
i worry about is the way in which social
media can split us into these uh very
tiny tribes right so for a lot of uh the
history of of of these diverse societies
the tribes were kind of relatively big
right i mean perhaps those two tribes in
a society perhaps was 10 perhaps verse
50. um but there were these
long-standing religious cultural
ethno-linguistic
groups
um
social media
kind of certain circumstances deepen the
attachment to them and deepen mistrust
against outsiders but a lot of the time
what happens is actually a slightly
different problem which is
uh
you know here's a good story from
twitter right like this vegan activist
who has a lot of followers and posts
about how anybody is not vegan is kind
of bad and all that stuff but
um
and then she she lives in a suburb in
the states and she you know comes home
and she sees the little little girl
who's crying
and she walks up to the lord are you
okay what's going on why are you crying
he said oh my friends brought ice cream
and i didn't have money to buy ice cream
and said oh the truck's still there come
on buy an ice cream and she posted you
know nice little story about this on
twitter right what do you think happens
next well obviously all of her hardcore
fans turn on her and say
you know how can you sell out like this
you've become a shill for the dairy
industry you know how dare you buy this
ice cream that contains dairy for those
kids um
and that's a political problem for us
it's a little bit different i think in
nature right because suddenly we have
not five or 10 or 50 but a thousand
groups that are just fanatical in
their advocacy of some particular issue
and then we have a political system
where you have two political parties or
perhaps five or six political parties in
some countries
and they just can't
bundle these thousand groups in any
meaningful way anymore and that's a real
political problem but perhaps one way of
uh
that goes with a larger point what i
want to make which is that
look when i look at
the thing that so many people are
worrying about right now the state of
these countries with all these different
ethnic and and and religious and
cultural groups i'm pretty optimistic i
think integration is working pretty well
in britain and the united states and i
think we societies
before we still have problems but we
still have injustices are much more
tolerant and much more integrated than
there were 50 or even 25
years ago and so i'm really optimistic
about that when i look at the political
level i'm really worried right i'm
worried about the 2024 elections in the
united states i'm worried about the
fragmentation of our politics i'm
worried about just the assumption that
anybody who doesn't agree 100
with your party line within that tiny uh
group whether it's vegans or some other
thing it's just an evil person right
like and social media has a lot to do
with with that piece of it
yeah and that's the thing yeshua in that
i see it as being such a divisive
influence that you've mentioned about a
thousand groups i can see those thousand
groups in two years time splitting into
ten thousand groups
and like you said these political
parties they're not going to be able to
hold all these groups together the prime
example of that is the labour party
in the in the uk where they simply can't
hold you know the the old style you know
left-wing socialists with the new
left-wing or the new left progressives
and everything else in between and the
center is it simply doesn't work so what
does that so what does that mean for our
political systems
well you know one thing that i am struck
by is that
uh
politicians that try to sustain a
unifying message
actually do relatively well
and so the problem is that you know the
people who are active in politics often
are the most strident advocates for one
of those different kinds of groups
and they often think of the near enemy
as much worse than a fire enemy right
the person within the political party
who has slight disagreements
uh
deserves to die you know
who cares about the tories you know we
can forget about them right the
important thing is that the person we
have a faction is sort of uh subjugated
right
um and that's a very old mechanism by
the way in the first
treaty series on freedom of religion uh
people were saying well you know we
really should have some tolerance
towards jews and muslims because they're
misguided and you know we can sort of
put up with them but christian apostates
they deserve death right like that's
unacceptable so this mechanism is a
really really old one actually
um
but when you have politicians that
manage to transcend that a little bit
that are not captive
uh
to these activist groups that speak a
language of of unity but actually
try to address
uh the country as a whole
um but it tends to do pretty well so you
know in the primaries for the democratic
party in 2020
um
you know every of the 16 candidates
basically 15 of them
we're running after twitter and we're
running after the most extreme voices of
it and that really represents what
vertice wanted
and the reason why joe biden is the
president of the united states is that
he's too old to follow twitter
and so
despite some personal weaknesses which
are which are also evident with him uh
he actually was speaking to the middle
of a party in the middle of a country in
a completely different way than his
competitors and their primaries now he's
not always kept up as much as he should
but but i think that shows something but
a candidate who's not full of charisma
and youthful stride was able to win out
against all these other candidates
precisely because he wasn't caught by
that and you know you mentioned the
labor party
you know i'm i'm certainly not a super
fan of kierstama i think he he too has
some weaknesses but there's not a
surprise but he's doing a lot better in
the polls than jeremy corbyn was um and
that is because he is trying to speak uh
to to the middle of a country rather
than to the activist base of parts of
the labour party much more than his
predecessor
yes it's a very interesting point you
make
particularly
given that i think one of the things
that's starting to happen is twitter is
bleeding through into politics and so
you're seeing uh the wedge issues of the
culture war coming through and becoming
real for politicians that are maybe not
quite able to deal with them or
uncertain of the right approach so you
know we have these endless debates about
defining what a woman is something that
about three years ago everybody had the
answer to now everybody's worried about
saying the right thing
so how do you think politicians will
tackle the need to on the one hand as
you say reach to speak to a broad
coalition while on the other hand
constantly being asked these sort of
twitter-based questions you know what is
a woman where should a trans woman be
kept you know when if if that trans
woman commits a crime should trans women
be in sport i i mean i can go on and on
in in every in every area of this sort
of cultural discussion how are they
going to be dealing with that in order
to solve some of the problems that you
you address in the book
um
look the the first good point is simply
to remember that twitter does not
represent public opinion right
so um i see this in journalism 20 years
ago 30 years ago i mean i wasn't around
but from what people tell me
uh you know people had a healthy sense
that a letter to the editor does not
represent the average view of your
readers right because most people read
an article and they say oh interesting i
agree with it oh well i don't agree with
it but we're not going to go and write
to you about it so who writes to you
about it the person who's triggered
right the person is like this is
terrible this is wrong right and so when
was a little bit of a transaction cost
people realized oh if we get a bunch of
letters about this article saying that
you know it's terrible and offensive or
whatever
you know perhaps that we represent
something that our readers think perhaps
it doesn't perhaps just means that like
0.1 percent of our readers feel very
strongly about this in some direction
and so you know people would print
leaders to be added to and you know
there was a whole culture around it but
but people knew that they couldn't just
assume this actually
represents what people think in the
world with twitter we've somehow lost
that lesson and it's because it's public
right like with letters to the editor
you know how many came in but your
readers don't everybody else doesn't so
someone feels less humiliating or it
feels less worrying right whereas on
twitter if you say something and
everybody pounces on you for it it feels
like you've been like publicly shamed
yeah and so then you're like oh my god
how do i avoid being publicly ashamed in
that kind of way um and so double down
yeah you double down you doubt that's
the answer
and
and never apologize for [ __ ] like
you've done something wrong say it but
never apologize when in fact you haven't
yeah
but
but that makes a real difference because
suddenly we know that on the left and on
the right the people who use twitter
actively are very extreme relative to
the average of a population because most
people have better things to do than to
are you on twitter all day long i say
with a lot of followers who spends way
too much time on twitter but i'm you
know i'm political scientist i care
about politics i think about over time
most people don't right and and most
people have pretty moderate opinions
actually and so so so the first thing to
do is simply
spend less time on twitter if you're an
important decision maker
look much more opinion posts much look
much more
at focus groups in which you hear
ordinary people actually talking out
issues when you do it what you see on
twitter because you're going to
miscalculate about where people
are that's the first lesson for for
political candidates um in particular
the second is when there's a firestorm
on on social media right when one of
your employees is being targeted if you
need an institution
just wait it out a couple days right
nearly all the time people get bored of
these campaigns they just need somebody
to shout at that day because they woke
up on the wrong side of the bed
and by the next day we're going to be
shouting at somebody else
right so rather than firing somebody
rather than jumping to some huge
conclusion about how you're going to
change your organization
just assess it
in in a calm way if there's accusations
that somebody in your organization did
something heinously wrong
investigate if it's true that it did do
something
substantively wrong
there should be consequences if if it's
the sort of thing for which there should
be consequences but don't just fire them
the moment that 200 people on twitter
are calling for their heads that's a
huge mistake and so i think you know
social media is always going to be a
little bit crazy and that's actually
fine i don't worry about what happens on
social media i worry about what happens
off social media i worry about the
inability of our institutions to
actually
put that in context
and and and act on it in appropriate
ways
it's
that is a very very very good point
yeshua what do we do
with what you were talking about and the
need to have these you know melting pot
societies as it were things to be more
homogenous
in the era of globalization where people
are becoming more fluid about where they
live if you take the european union
freedom of movement doesn't that mean
that that sort of
state that you want to work towards in
that state of living
is becoming ever more difficult and dare
i say old-fashioned
you know
my impressions always but that's not the
case and like i'm as close to a damn
cosmopolitan as they come i mean not
only am i jewish but you know i grew up
in germany and i've lived in italy and
france and i went to college in britain
and i you know i'm living in the states
now i have two passports you know
but like i i
i wouldn't up and leave and live
anywhere in the world and i have a
pretty strong sense of belonging
actually and perhaps it's a bit more
complicated than others but it certainly
doesn't extend to every place in the
world
um and most people are way less mobile
have way less experience living in other
countries uh have way more family and
friends in one particular place
than i do so i think some of those
descriptions i know david goodhart in
england likes to go on about with sort
of you know
um the cosmopolitan elite that really uh
you know are people of nowhere i just
don't know many of them
um you know most people
uh yeah if you're pretty educated and
and perhaps have some money you're very
comfortable flying to x y or that place
tomorrow for two weeks
but after two weeks most people want to
go home
uh you know perhaps if you're in your
20s and you have a professional
opportunity to go live in a country for
a few years plus a bunch of people who
love the idea of that
but after that most of them want to go
home or they decide hey i fall in love
here i've stayed here and i'm going to
make my home here but i'm going to build
roots here and stay in this new country
and actually really be rooted there you
know
the number of people who really are sort
of like we live in hong kong for two
years and went in london for three years
and uh you know then venom rio de
janeiro for five years and you know then
and so for one year that is an extremely
extremely extremely small number of
people
i would say we've had david on the show
and just so to defend him a little bit i
think his argument is a little more
complex than that because his argument
isn't that uh say someone like you and
you you are definitely in anywhere in
his conception uh you might have a
feeling of attachment to new york or
london or wherever you live but uh
what his point was that most people who
are of that persuasion they're never
going to go back to the small town from
which they come uh or indeed they've
probably never lived there since they
went to university and so that that
formation of long-term community bonds
the deep attachment to a sense of place
the perhaps some of the anxieties about
rapid change that that come with having
that sort of community attachment are
not as strong and and that i think is
probably the difference between you and
someone who grew up in i don't know uh
wigan and lived in wigan their whole
life and had a job that is very much
tied into to the city and their friends
and family all live there and their
identities that and they go to the rugby
games and and and on and goes i think
that's the difference
so so that's fair but i think um when
his terminology doesn't work very well
we're getting a little bit in detail on
this particular theory here but i think
it actually says something about where
the problem lies and where it doesn't
lie what i see around me
is people who have a very strong sense
of belonging
to particular places and particularly to
to communities that they're a part of
they're not
these individualists who
lack social ties they are people who are
part of
an affluent neighborhood somewhere who
are part of perhaps a university town
with a campus and a strong community who
are part of a very strong professional
circle with you know fearing the
judgment of their peers in a very very
strong way they have very strong
attachments the problem is that we have
an educational socio-economic elite that
often has become uh
dissociated from a lot of the rest of
the country socioeconomically right and
so
you know they look down on them on the
middle of a country they look down
people are less educated they look down
and people don't speak the same fancy
language as them they look down and
people who use
the wrong term which is one that's been
invented in the last two years but
that's not because they're people of
anywhere who can up and leave or who can
you know it's because actually they're
really afraid what people are going to
say to them within the community at the
next dinner party
right
um
and they actually have this extremely
strong form of peer pressure
um uh which helps to explain why
you can go from one view to the next in
a year and anybody who deviates from it
in a slight way is sort of
subject to these pretty extreme forms of
social punishment and so to me this is
groupism right to me this is actually
uh yes i'm a member of this particular
group and part of the identity of this
group is to look down on other groups
within our society but it's not hey it's
individuals who are people from anywhere
and they don't have affiliations it is
an extremely strong group affiliation
uh
but one that's developed among uh
you know an educational and to some
extent socioeconomic elite that has
become uh disjointed from from from less
educated people so i don't know perhaps
david and i are saying the same thing
perhaps you're saying you are you are i
think you'd actually agree yeah yeah so
that being the case is and this elite
group of people they don't only have a
disdain
and i use that when i use that word
accurately i think for people that they
deem from a lower class than them or
however you want to describe it but
there is also a disdain amongst that
group of people for the nation state
particularly in the america and the
united kingdom where they feel a sense
of shame that they come from the united
kingdom or america and as a result
doesn't that also mean we're losing
harmony in that instance because once
you start to want to detach from the
nation state
then what you're really doing is saying
that you know that we no longer have a
collective identity
well we saw we saw that in britain with
the labour party and its debate over the
british flag recently right
um where where the idea of a major
political party embracing the flag of
its country um becomes becomes somehow
controversial which is a huge mistake
because the nation continues to have
this strong symbolism and the strong
emotional power and if you're leaving it
to
uh
you know especially with far-right
fringes that becomes really dangerous
right i mean that's a lot of what went
wrong what allowed some really dangerous
people to to to win political power
um
so so so i agree but i actually think
the the biggest problem is just
it's people
no longer believing the basic thing you
have to believe
to actually be a small d democrat
right so you can despair of your fellow
citizens you can say my god they voted
for this person who a dislike or they
you know made a big mistake morally on
this issue a majority of my fellow
citizens think something that i think is
really bad and wrong
that's fine right democracy doesn't mean
that you always have to agree with a
majority and it doesn't mean that you
always have to love your fellow citizens
but
to believe in democracy you do have to
think that most people are capable of
doing the right thing most of the time
but most people
are decent human beings who are
responsive to urgent moral reasons and
you might lose some debates you might
lose some important debates
but
but you still have to retain the hope
that you can convince them the next time
around
and and what i see a little bit in
in in my intellectual circles
is that that's been lost over the last
years but a lot of people have started
to think you know
the average citizen
is just a bigot you know the average
citizen is just a bad human being
and
uh and that really that really worries
me um
even more
yeah well i know i i suspect there's a
version of it that comes in other
circles that you you don't swim in on
perhaps the other side of the of the
discussion too where there's you know i
think
it's almost like the stakes have been
raised so much now that we can no longer
accept losing because losing is
existential now if we lose then you know
the the left-wing argument would be well
then roe v wade gets overturned and this
happens and that happens and on the
right
likewise it's like we're losing our
country and we're losing to these people
who hate our country and by the way the
most loud people on twitter
do hate this country you know see if you
look at that you're kind of going well
that sort of makes sense
um so you know we've got a few minutes
left before we ask you our questions for
locals yasha
you seem positive you seem optimistic in
a few minutes how are we gonna get to
the sunny uplands where we're all living
peaceful ever after
well look um
let me start because we haven't talked
that much about it
with some of the things that make me
positive about the current situation
right so look we have problems of
some amount of fragmentation in our
society and we have problems with
injustice and racism in our society and
both of those are real
um but just the current state of our
society is a lot better than than people
think and it's a lot better than it was
a few decades ago look
i'm in san francisco right now as we're
having this conversation
30 years ago in the united states a
majority of americans thought that
interracial marriage was immoral but it
was immoral for a white and a black
american to marry each other
today that figure is down to a single
digits it's plummeted in the course of a
of a few decades
um and we know that this is a change in
in reality not just in in what people
are comfortable telling pollsters
uh because of real change in in hoover
maryland and who they're having kids
with um a few decades ago about one in
33 americans where when you born now
it's about one in seven right that's
very rapid and very significant change
in the nature of society well let's take
immigration right on the far right you
have people who say uh look immigrants a
hundred years ago
from italy and in ireland in the united
states for example they succeeded
because they were the right kind of
immigrants right was immigrants coming
in today from el salvador and vietnam
and kenya they are not succeeding
because there's something somehow
inferior about them right
now
people on the left and in the mainstream
of society rightly reject that
attribution of blame
but i'm struck by how often they echo
the pessimism they say yeah it's true
that these immigrants today they're
really not succeeding you know
they're not doing well but the reason is
that our country is so racist and so
discriminatory which don't stand a
chance
no there is discrimination there is
racism but actually the best studies
show that this pessimism is simply
misplaced but um yes the first
generation often struggles yes it's a
slow process of socioeconomic progress
of educational mobility
but actually immigrants from all these
countries i mentioned are rising the
socio-economic ranks are rising
educational ranks at about the same
speed as immigrants from italy and
ireland did 100 years ago
now what that proves is that there's
nothing inferior about them but the
far-right is obviously wrong about that
but what it also proves
is that uh our society is not so unjust
and so discriminatory that we don't
stand a chance we have a chance and
we're seizing it and that's something we
should celebrate
um
so what i see is
a political level that's really really
screwed up a really dangerous kind of
cultural civil war of the elites which
is trying to be imposed on the rest of
society but actually a lot of very
reasonable people
in the middle of society going about
their lives making connections with each
other
uh
integrating with each other
and the question is well we're going to
be able to sustain
that progress in the in the coming
decades now you know i talk in the book
a whole lot about a bunch of policies
that we can pursue you know it's easier
to tolerate your neighbor and to be open
to newcomers when
you have economic growth and you feel
like you know if you lose your job
you're not going to be impoverished and
when you feel the political institutions
are inclusive and there's all kinds of
little policies and reforms we can pass
in order to sustain those background
conditions
but but but my
real optimism comes from from from the
actual changes we already are making in
society perhaps one last point
um
americans have completely accepted and
i'm starting to see a similar kind of
rhetoric creep in in the united kingdom
that
the country is going to be majority
minority by 2045 or something like that
and that this is giving democrats this
sort of rising political majority
and this is the one thing
that
democrats and republicans in this
country agree on
and it's wrong and it's dangerous
it is wrong because
actually voting behavior is way more
complicated than that
um in the 1960s irish americans were one
of the most reliable virtual groups for
democrats now they're one of the most
reliable voter groups for republicans
donald trump was competitive in the 2020
elections because he increased his share
of a vote among every non-white voter
groups compared to 2016 among african
americans among asian americans
particularly among latinos and joe biden
is the 46th president of the united
states because he significantly improved
his share of the world among white
vertices relative to hillary clinton so
we've actually seen a racial
depolarization
of the electorate in the last years and
that's a good thing i don't want to live
in a country where i can look at the
color of your skin and know who you're
voting for
that sounds terrible and dangerous
but i go even one step further i no
longer believe that america is ever
going to be majority minority
now
if you accept
the definition of united states census
bureau if you accept the one drop rule
generalized to every demographic group
if you accept that anybody who has
you know
seven white and one asian grandparent
is a person of color
right if you accept that anybody who has
any kind of concept connection to
a spanish or portuguese-speaking country
like
my brazilian uber driver yesterday who
dropped him
who dropped him
who picked me up from the airport who
had a boston hour 2022
uh hat in his car and told me about how
much he loves donald trump you know if
you think
that those people all define as people
of color and that they're naturally on
the left politically then perhaps all of
this view of the future of america might
be right but that's just a really
strange way
of of looking at the world and so i
think what's what's actually happening
is what this assault richard alba has
described a sort of broadening of the
american mainstream
um by the time at which in some
technical level america's gonna be a
majority minority
uh it just won't make sense and it
already doesn't make much sense to
describe the country somewhere naturally
split into this monolithic group of
white people in this monolithic group of
people of color so if you're a racist
who just cares about the purity of white
people and the things that you know any
non-white ancestor that any american has
somehow makes them impure and makes them
non-white then it makes sense to say
that america is going to be majority
minority by 2045. if you're somebody
who's actually thinking about
sociological reality and people's
self-conception how they think about
themselves how they interact
who's friends with whom who's married
with whom how people are voting this
whole concept doesn't make any sense
yeah yeah sure thank you so much for
coming on the show it's been a pleasure
uh if people want to find you online if
they want to buy your book how do they
do that
um well by the great experiment um it's
called in the united states called the
great experiment why diverse democracies
fall apart and how they can endure in
the uk it's called the great experiments
uh how to make diverse democracies work
you can buy it in your bookstore you can
buy it on terrible online retailers like
amazon you can buy it anywhere um
three more plugs follow me on twitter
yasha underscore monk y-a-s-c-h-a
underscore m-o-u-n-k
listen to my podcast the good fight um
and subscribe to my online publication
called persuasion which tries to stand
up for philosophically liberal values
against its many attackers
from the left and the right
fantastic cashier well uh before we let
you go we've got a couple of questions
you fo from our local supporters that
only they will see but before that our
final question is always the same what
is the one thing that we're not talking
about as a society that you think we
really should be
i'm going to go to a completely
different topic
uh look i i i don't know whether aliens
exist you know we probably don't and
we're probably not going to make contact
with them
but but if you know anything
about human history and what it means to
be colonized you should know that it is
a very bad idea to be sending signals
out into outer space saying hey aliens
if you're around here we are we're
sitting ducks come and get us uh and
that's what humanity is doing i think we
shouldn't
and by the point by the way the point
has been made on that is any
civilization and that's not not from the
earth that was capable of coming here
would probably be a lot more powerful
than we were so maybe you're you're
right perhaps the wonderful altruistic
beings that just want to share their
fancy food with us or perhaps they want
to do terrible things to us as most
human societies did when we had the
gunsmith technologies to go and
subjugate other human societies
there's a nice positive note
fantastic stuff well uh thanks for
joining us sasha we're going to ask you
our questions from our locals in a
second but for now thank you so much for
joining us uh watching the show
listening to it we will see you very
soon with another brilliant episode like
this one or also all of which go out at
7 pm uk time and for those of you who
like your trigonometry on the go it's
also available as a podcast take care
and see you soon guys
what would be the effect of a democracy
falling apart would it be like the old
yugoslavia for example would england
collapse into disparate nation states
[Music]
you